one of the biggest breaks on the Ukraine
story has happened in the last 24 hours
with the release of testimony from
ambassador to the European Union Gordon
sunland now I'm going to go through this
with you because the guy that Trump has
been pointing to saying look he says
there was no quid pro quo that guy has
now testified that there was a quid pro
quo so this is major but there's
actually a bigger issue to address here
there is a I guess I would call it let's
use a building analogy there's a
systemic rot that is taking over the
issue of Ukraine for Donald Trump and
for Republicans and for the last few
weeks the foundation has been starting
to fracture and rot and weaken below
ground level right it was only visible
though if you were standing in the
basement but outside they were still
keeping up the facade of the house as if
it were solid and strong but over the
last 48 hours that foundational rod has
started to be noticeable from the
outside because the house is starting to
implode on itself it can't be avoided
even standing out in the street you see
the house starting to slump over in
disrepair and Republicans don't know
what to do because they can't defend
Donald Trump anymore on the facts early
on they were trying to defend Donald
Trump on the facts there was no quid pro
quo the phone call was fine the military
aid so on and so forth they now have
been relegated to just having to attack
the whistleblower like Kentucky Senator
Rand Paul did and which we talked about
yesterday or the day before Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham a month ago said
there's no evidence of a quid pro quo
now there is thanks in part to Gordon
Sunland so Lindsey Graham now is saying
I'm not even going to read his testimony
because it's just not worth my time
what well then you shouldn't get your
175,000 a year from taxpayers right if
you're not even willing to do your job
at least you shouldn't get your hundred
and seventy five thousand he probably
will continue to so here's what happened
Donald Trump has been saying for weeks
Gordon Sunland the ambassador to the
European Union he said it
there was no quid pro quo on my call
with Ukraine so clearly Donald Trump
believed
we can trust the word of Gordon sunland
right well no it's Trump you can trust
the word of Gordon Sunland if his word
is convenient for Donald Trump
remember that Gordon Sunland was
appointed by Donald Trump Sunland was a
major Trump mega donor who gave a
million dollars to Trump's inauguration
by the way that entire thing is another
fiasco that needs to be fixed these
inauguration funds serve effectively as
slush money for what is effectively
political bribery and influence peddling
but that's a story for a different day
but Gordon Sunland has now amended his
testimony saying you know what Trump's
dealings with Ukraine they were a quid
pro quo
sunlen talks about a meeting that
happened on September 1st with a top
aide to the Ukrainian president during
which it was made clear according to
sunland US military aid to Ukraine is
contingent upon President Solinsky
publicly saying he's launching
investigations into Joe Biden which
Donald Trump wanted in order to help him
in his 2020 reelection campaign so
that's it right I mean whistleblowers
are now irrelevant the guy Trump
appointed who said we should be looking
for him for the truth says there was a
quid pro quo now let's get into the
reaction to this because we knew that
any time there's an amended testimony
that is not convenient for Donald Trump
the conspiracy theories would start it
would start so if you ask Republicans
why did Gordon Sunland first say one
thing and now say something else they
are coming up with all sorts of theories
and the most popular one is the Dems got
to Sunland they threatened his life they
made it clear that they'll destroy his
family and his career if he doesn't lie
and say there was a quid pro quo is that
theoretically possible sure but with so
many other people who are corroborating
the same story
why do Democrats need to do something
criminal in threatening Gordon Sunland
in this way in order to get just one guy
to change his testimony when there are
so many other people that are saying the
exact same thing happened the more
likely scenario is that earlier on
Gordon Sunland didn't yet know how big
the Ukraine Fiasco was going to get
sunlen thought I can get away with some
kind of melee
a statement saying this is sort of what
I recall right now things might be
missing I might update my testimony in
the future and hoping it would all sort
of die down and that he wouldn't end up
actually a part of a much bigger scandal
it's now clear it's not going away it's
now clear that everybody else who was
involved who has any knowledge of what
happened with Ukraine says there was a
quid pro quo and Sunland simply has to
come totally clean which he is now doing
tell me what you think explains Gordon
sunland's change of position on this
issue I believe that Republicans have
absolutely no evidence whatsoever for
their theory that he was strong-armed
pressured threatened by Democrats I mean
it just there's no evidence whatsoever
and absent evidence what I would imagine
is that he went in as as many people who
have to give testimony do initially
what's best for them is to say as little
as possible to be as least controversial
as they can be with the hopes that
they'll be forgotten because people
generally don't like the idea of having
to go and testify in these ways that
didn't happen and he is now coming
totally clean that's my view let me know
either leave a comment if you're
watching on youtube send me a tweet I'm
on twitter at D Pakman and while you're
there make sure you're following me I am
approaching 100,000 Twitter followers
are completely arbitrary and meaningless
but nice-looking round number and I
would appreciate your helping getting to
that tonight livestream join me on
twitch at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
the David Pakman show is possible thanks
to sponsors like VIN Charo watches
giving everyone in our audience 15% off
your entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch I just got a
couple of new watches from these guys
and I love them I got the Kairos limited
release gold reserve set which is very
cool I love the white face the simple
band and everything about it it's a
perfect size for my wrist really great
choice I also picked out the Ventura
bellwether in silver and white and what
I love about this one
number one the Roman numeral at the top
of the face the white face is great this
is a cronograph model and I love the
blue leather band it's just a really
nice looking watch everybody who sees me
wear this one always asks about it what
I like about Vince arrow as a watch
brand is you're getting quality and
you're getting a watch where it's clear
as soon as you open the box that a lot
of care and artisanship went into the
design and the way that the watch is put
together I'm not interested in paying
thousands of dollars for a watch when I
can get one that's reasonably priced and
looks just as nice and has terrific
build quality and that's exactly what
Vince arrow is in the business of doing
putting a ton of craftsmanship into
their watches making them available for
a hundred and fifty two hundred bucks
you really can't go wrong check them out
at david pakman.com slash watch support
the people who support our show and
you'll save fifteen percent when you use
that link